مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجتنباء من قناه
الجزيره اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
استشهاد الشابين برصاص القوات الاحتلال
خلال اقتحامها نابلس وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان قواته نفذت عمليه امنيه في
المدينه لاعتقال مطلوبين على صله بهجوم
حواره الذي وقع قبل اسبوع وادى لاصابه
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين
اكد جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تعرضت لاطلاق
نار من دون ان يخلف ذلك اصابات كما اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي وان بلده تعاونيه داخل
الخط الاخضر تعرضت لاطلاق نار من شمال
الضفاد الغربيه من دون ان يخلف الحادث اي
اصابات واعلنت كتيبه جنينه تابعه للاسراء
القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ولواء الشهداء في كتائب الاقصى
الجناح المسلح لفتح عن استهداف بلده ميراث
الاسرائيليه شرق جنين
ارجع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي اقاله وزير
دفاعه وقال نتنياهو امام جمعا من الجنود
الاسرائيليين بحضر وزير الدفاع انه يجب
ابقاء سياسه السياسه خارج بوابات معسكرات
الجيش من اجل دفاع عن وجود اسرائيل الابدي
حسب تعبيره
انهت المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه جلسه
للنظر في التماس ضد تعيين اجمار بن جفير
وزيرا في الحكومه حيث يحتج مقدم الالتماس
على تعيين ابن كثير في هذا المنصب الحساس
بسببه ماضيه الجنائي
اعلنت فنلندا انها ستنضم رسميا الى حلف
الناتو اليوم الثلاثاء واكد الامين العام
للحلف ينص السلطان هذه الخطوه ستجعله حلف
الناتو اقوى
جهه
العسكريه على المحورين الغربي والشمالي
الغربي ردا على انضمام فنلندا الى النيتو
وقال انه جرى الاعلان عن بعض الاجراءات
التي من شانها ان تقوي امكانات روسيا
العسكريه على هذين المحورين في حال نشر
قوات ومعدات من قبل اعضاء اخرين بالنيتو
في فنلندا
تضارب التاء الروايات بشان السيطره على
مدينه بخموت فقد نقلت وكاله ان القوات
الروسيه اقتربت من خط السكه الحديديه
الرئيسيه في بخموت وبثى رئيسه شركه فاقنر
صورا ليليه قال فيها انه يرفع العالم
الروسي في المركز الاداري في المدينه
وصل الرئيس الامريكي السابق الى نيويوركس
استعدادا لمثوله امام المحكمه في منهج في
وقت لاحق اليوم الثلاثاء في قضيه دفعه
ريشا لشراء صمت ممثله اباحيه قبيل
انتخابات 2016 واجتمعت مع محاميه للتحضير
لدفاعه واكد محاموه ان موكلهم سيدفع
ببراءته ونفى الناطق باسم شرطه نيويورك
وجود اي تهديدات جديه واكدت سلطات الولايه
الضمانها حق التعبير بطرق سلميه
مشاهدي
[موسيقى]